Speaker 1: You truly cannot write this stuff.
Another Republican I'm not talking now about
George Anthony, David or Santos. I'm talking
about a different Republican who claimed Jewish
heritage. And it turns out she's not only lying.
Her grandfather was a Nazi. I it's what a world
that we live in. Article from the Jerusalem Post.
Congresswoman claims to be Jewish. Revealed to be
the granddaughter of a Nazi. We are talking about
new republican Congresswoman ana Paulina luna.
She has claimed Jewish heritage previously, and
it turns out her grandfather, heinrich maier
Hoffer. And this is not the. This is not like
a Jack Maier Hoffer moment when Bill O'Reilly
got pranked by that. This is genuinely the guy's
name. Heinrich Maier Hoffer, who died in 2003,
served in the armed forces of Nazi Germany when
he was a teenager in the forties. You really
should read this entire Jpost article. It's wild,
wild stuff. Florida Republican Congresswoman Anna
Paulina Luna was outed by the Washington Post
Friday for lying about her Jewish heritage in
a previous interview with the Jewish Insider.
Not only is Luna almost certainly not Jewish,
but according to several family members, according
to the Post, Luna's paternal grandfather,
Heinrich Maier Hoffer, who died in 2003, served in
the armed forces of Nazi Germany as a teenager in
the forties. Luna had told the Jewish insider,
I was raised as a messianic Jew by my father,
clarifying, She identifies as a Christian. I
am also a small fraction Ashkenazi. Now she's
speaking ethnically, of course. The Insider
had interviewed Luna in reaction to the fact
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE, known for her Jewish
space laser conspiracy, endorsed Luna's candidacy
if she were anti-Semitic, asked Luna, after
claiming Ashkenazi roots, why did she endorse me?
I, in no way, shape or form would ever put
myself in a position where I'm hanging out
with someone like that. And so I just don't see
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE is that person. If
I see it happening on the right, I'm the
first person to condemn it and say like,
Hey, that's not cool. I don't align with that.
Reminiscent of Hillary Clinton's, I told Wall
Street to cut it out, which they laughed about,
but now this is taken seriously. Luna has also
invoked Nazis in her political rhetoric. In 2021,
she tweeted a video insinuating that a registry
of Americans who are not vaccinated against
COVID would be like the Nazi list of Jews.
This is very, very quickly becoming another George
Santos situation as the lies are piling up. Now,
some people wrote to me and said, David, you know,
sure, she's a liar. But like, what's so bad about
saying your one religion when you're just not
that religion? Like, David, if you said you
were Baptist and you weren't Baptist, it wouldn't
really be offensive. It would be a lie, but it
would be offensive. It wouldn't be offensive.
You really have to understand what Judaism is.
Being Jewish is not just a religion. Judaism is
a cultural identity. If you were if you didn't
convert into Judaism, you're also ethnically
Jewish. Like when I did, my DNA came back. Oh,
David, you're Ashkenazi. That's an ethnicity.
I could change my beliefs into whatever
Mormonism. I'd still be ethnically Jewish. And
there's a history, ethnically and culturally,
in addition to religiously, which has faced
centuries of persecution, really millennia. It's
an ethno religious group. And so when you falsely
claim Jewish heritage, you're not only erasing the
experiences and the struggles of actual Jewish
people, you also perpetuate stereotypes. You're
participating in cultural appropriation. So it's
not like a harmless act. It is deception. It is a
lie. At the end of the day. But it's a particular
type of lie that under undermines trust and
respect. So George Santos, George Anthony of
older Santos did this falsely claiming Jewish
heritage and opposing a Luna has done it. And
then lastly, there's one other wrinkle here.
Pretending to be Jewish and then exonerating
Marjorie Taylor GREENE ferment accusations of
anti-Semitism with your fake Jewishness is like
another particularly disgusting layer to the
entire thing. So it is not only Santos that is
participating in these and many other lies. If
you're curious about Luna's other lies. There's a
number of articles about it now which you can find
ugly, ugly stuff. We're going to take a very quick
break. Make sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel. Make sure you're subscribed to the
Spanish YouTube channel. What? What? David, what
are you talking about? Later on in the show, I'll
tell you all about what's going on in Spanish.